líderes europeos y africanos junto a
diversas instituciones se reunieron este
martes en parís para darle una salida a
la crisis financiera de áfrica su
economía debilitada se ha visto golpeada
por la pandemia de kobe 19 a pesar de
que áfrica tan sólo cuenta con 130 mil
muertes por el virus frente a las 3,4
millones en el mundo una situación que
el presidente manuel macro no quiere
combatir hoy es la pandemia pero hay
otras pandemias que afectan a áfrica
desde hace demasiados años esta crisis
económica y social es el epicentro del
terrorismo internacional que se extiende
en áfrica por el bien común el fondo
monetario internacional también defendió
brindar ayuda financiera al continente
we get to roots
tenemos que impulsar el crecimiento las
inversiones públicas y privadas en
áfrica y podemos hacerlo movilizando la
financiación de las organizaciones
internacionales de los donantes
bilaterales y por supuesto de los
propios países
a pesar de haber experimentado
crecimiento económico en los últimos
años áfrica se enfrenta a un déficit de
290 mil millones de dólares que amenaza
su desarrollo hasta 2023 una recesión
que se suma el problema del terrorismo
islámico que tienen que enfrentar varias
naciones de la región como cuando se
trata de áfrica deberíamos ver cómo
podemos a nivel de comunidades
económicas regionales proponer una red
de seguridad financiera que nos permita
hacer frente a este tipo de crisis
la deuda pública y la pobreza se
disparan en el continente según el banco
africano de desarrollo en 2021 39
millones de africanos podrían caer en
situación de pobreza